foreign
[Music]
against the 2210
when in doubt sacked the king okay
hopefully we'll be making our opponent
do that e45
and of course we play Knight F3
and as I was explaining uh in in the
last video there's a dilemma I have when
I get to
uh the higher higher ratings
where on the one hand I want to play
what I recommend which in this case is
the fortnite scotch on the other hands
we're facing opponents who are strong to
the point where I would be more
comfortable playing my main repertoire
but with that said I still think the
fortnite scotch is so powerful a weapon
at most levels that we're gonna play it
here and uh we're gonna see how our
opponent reacts to it another
alternative is to actually play the
Belgrade Gambit
um which is e takes D4 and Knight T5 and
I've played the Belgrade a a very good
amount in uh
semi-competitive tournament games like I
played it in a rapid tournament against
vidit and got a good position I played
it against Eric Hansen so I've done a
fair amount of analysis in the Belgrade
and I think it's a much more dangerous
Gambit than it's given credit for
um it's considered to be a completely
unsound line that was last popular in
the 1970s and is basically buried under
a pile of rubble so our choice is to
play Knight takes C4 and go into the
mainline scotch
but as a nice little wrinkle let's throw
a knight D5 at our opponent and let's
see how a good player reacts to an
unexpected opening surprise so Knight T5
is called the Belgrade Gambit if you're
watching this on YouTube you very likely
are seeing this move for the first time
now maybe you've seen me play this in
Blitz
um and it's a Gambit because well
obviously you don't recapture the D4
Pawn which may seem crazy but the
centralization of the Knight faces black
with a couple of immediate problems it
also faces black with a huge dilemma
where he has like six or seven
legitimate responses to the Belgrade
uh so there's Knight takes C4 which is
the most dangerous move uh for black
grabbing a second Pawn but giving white
like a massive initiative there's Knight
takes D5 which is the simplifying move
that's what vidit played against me and
he did not manage to equalize the book
recommendation as far as I know most
books recommend one of two moves one is
this weird move night before that you're
probably not gonna play unless like
unless you know the line because it just
doesn't occur to someone and the other
is the sort of simple modest move Bishop
E7 was developing the bishop and uh
essentially asking white what he's gonna
do with that Knight H6 is another very
reasonable move and the point of this
move is clear black is preventing Bishop
G5 which is one of White's main ideas
and the Belgrade to put immediate
pressure on this Knight and I'll give
you some context after the game I'll
kind of explain the the basics of the
Belgrade as as I understand it now
in this position
if you follow the kind of old
recommendations of the original
proponents of the Belgrade you're going
to get a terrible position like the
Belgrade as it was originally played
does not even come close to equalizing I
mean white can get close to a lost
position out of the opening but I
analyzed it with a strong engine and I
was able to find ways that you can kind
of liven up the opening and make moves
that are virtually unknown but give
white a very very decent chances and
this is one of those situations if I
remember correctly the move that I came
up with with the engine is Bishop to D3
and rarely did they did the original
Belgrade players kind of play in this
fashion they would usually go Bishop F4
they would recapture the pawn I don't
actually remember what the correct move
is here
um it might be Knight takes D4
yeah H6 is like the one move that I
don't remember I know that in response
to
there is a line where white plays Bishop
D3 and then repositions the bishop to G5
I actually think it is here
yeah I'm pretty sure it's Bishop to D3
and uh the line that I'm sort of
remembering is if black plays D6 here
you take the Knight and then you
reposition the bishop to B5 in order to
recapture the D4 Pawn the weird
semi-enginy kind of line
of course black can also try to develop
the bishop outside the pawn chain so
Bishop C5 is possible
but that move also comes with Associated
risks in particular that Bishop on C5
could be very vulnerable to a queen Side
Pawn storm and there's a common idea
where white plays A3 and B4 and apart
from forcing this bishop to many in many
cases lose contact with the d-pawn
you're also opening up a nice fiancado
Square for our dark squared Bishop of
course the other drawback of H6 thinking
very long term is that once black
Castle's King side if we do in fact
leave the bishop on its original
diagonal then there are situations where
the sacrifice on H6 can be very
dangerous
the basic thing to understand is that
Knight takes D5 is almost always in
White's favor because we recapture on D5
and several things happen first of all
the Knight on C6 is kicked away when
it's kicked away black runs the risk of
losing the D4 pawn and if black takes on
D5 too early and white is able to put a
rook on E1 black often just gets
massacred down the e-file so that is to
be avoided by experienced players D6 is
played
and now I'm pretty sure that my line
goes Knight takes F6 Queen takes F6 and
Bishop B5 we could also probably start
with Bishop B5
what is the minus of doing that if we
start with Bishop B5 and black takes the
pawn on e4 that I'm definitely not
scared of that then we can even just
castle and get a massive development
advantage
so I actually like the look of Bishop B5
immediately here
yeah let's do it Bishop B5 so we kind of
we've waited for black to play D6 and
now we reposition the bishop on B5
which is much more sensible than if we
had done it here because here Bishop B5
is kind of an empty move it doesn't pin
the Knight and so it loses a lot of its
effectiveness
now it does pin the night and it
threatens Knight takes D4 recapturing
the pawn with interest
so
very very complex position right out of
the gates and there's a lot of openings
like this that you can pick up on and
with with the with the aid of chessable
you can construct a repertoire that is
censored around these very tricky lines
that people still don't know very well
and the Belgrade is is definitely one of
them a lot of these lines have bad
reputations but if you analyze them
carefully King's Gambit also belongs in
that category where it's it's got this
reputation so people don't analyze it
and as a result if you study it very
carefully if you look at like nepo's
chessable course you can actually get
very very good positions out of these
openings
which is a side note to my main
recommendations in the speedrun which
are more mainstream but this is just you
know a piece of advice if you're trying
to construct a multi-faceted opening
repertoire like maybe you have a main
line and then you you're trying to find
you know side side openings to make your
experience more interesting but okay
right now we have to make a decision
the simple option is to play Bishop
takes C6 then Knight takes F6 and then
we can recapture the pawn on D4 either
with the queen or with the Knight and we
can recapture the sacrificed Pawn
and maybe get a very very modest
Advantage at best because we do ruin
black spawn structure in that position
but that pawn Mass on the queen side is
often not really considered a weakness
in these uh in E4 openings
and we also give black the bishop pair
and we give black on contested control
of the light squares so the other option
is just to keep the tension of Bishop A4
and I quite like the look of that
let's go Bishop well
yeah whatever no guts no glory let's go
Bishop A4 just keep the tension and
obviously we're allowing B5 but then the
bishop repositions to B3
and it eyes the F7 Pawn which of course
is a major weakness in these types of
positions foreign
intuitive guesses that Bishop A4 is
inferior objectively probably the best
is to take on C6 take on F6 and maybe
even take on D4 with the queen and play
that end game but again not really in
the spirit of the Belgrade and this
poses I think more practical problems to
Black
yeah there is a chessable course on the
Belgrade which probably has a lot of
these modern ideas you can check it out
but I'll look it up after the game and
give you a little bit of context on it
B5 okay so obviously
there's no need for us to take on F6
again that defeats the purpose the
purpose is maximum tension Knight to E5
ah so that is an interesting move
offering a second nitrate so let's rule
out the bad options I think taking on E5
makes zero sense it fixes the pawn
structure allows black to defend D4
so the obvious move to me is Knight
takes D4
what could our opponent be intending so
this kind of smells like a Noah's Ark
trap anytime you have this construction
and the Knight leaves C6 you have to
worry about the possibility of C5 C4
trapping the bishop and if C5 comes with
Tempo then that might be a major problem
and oftentimes you have to figure out
tactical ways to save this bishop so the
question is after Knight takes D4 C5 do
we have a way of saving our light
squared bishop tactically and I think we
do
I think we have a cool trick where we
can take on F6 with check
and then sorry the queen will recapture
so again take C5 takes takes we go
Bishop to D5
and we attack the exposed rook in the
corner and we jump ahead of the pawn of
the pawn storm
if the Rook moves then we can safely
move our Knight we can even move it up
to C6 and try to
rest the initiative from Black Sands
yeah I don't see much else that we that
we can do here other than Knight takes
D4
and I was just checking to see if black
can't get away with some sort of
exchange sacrifice but I think the coast
is clear
I think the coast is clear so Knight F6
and Bishop D5 so this is our idea
hopefully I'm not missing some tactic
here because one thing you have to
consider is C takes D4
and if we take the rook in the corner
there's a temporary moment where we're
kind of underdeveloped and Scattered and
Black's got this queen which is
menacingly aimed at f2 so I just took a
couple of seconds to verify that black
doesn't have any like immediate win in
that position so for instance CD Bishop
A8 Bishop G4 has to be considered
because who can tell me what happens if
in that position
you play Queen takes D4 a little bit of
visualization training and what should
white do instead of Queen takes D4
trickier question
because there is another really really
bad option in that position
so in that case black plays Knight F3
discovering an attack against the queen
and wins the queen
so the correct move I think after CD
Bishop a bishop G4 would also not be to
play Pawn F3 never play F3 because if
Knight takes F3 check and after black
recaptures on F3 there's a fork on the
queen and the Rook not to mention the
whites King is wide open in the center
so the careful option after Bishop G4
would be this very awkward looking move
Queen to D2
which is a move that I think a lot of
people have a natural resistance to
because it blocks the bishop but there's
bigger fish to fry here it's not about
positional principles we're up in
exchange so we just need to solve the
immediate problems also a benefit of
this little battery is that the queen
can go up to F4 later on and challenge
its counterpart on F6 so it's not all
bad
but when you're you know you always have
to know what the priorities are right
when you're trying to survive
and consolidate a material advantage
positional considerations and general
guidelines of development go on the back
burner completely and your your top
Allegiance is to keeping your king safe
and making sure you're not allowing your
opponent to keep the Flames of the
initiative going
and it's important I think to identify
these mental blocks like it's important
to identify where you're automatically
rejecting a particular type of move
everybody has certain moves that you
know certain triggering moves
lack of a better term and by identifying
them you're often able to root out sort
of preconceived notions of
what what's good and what's not if
Bishop G4 immediately well that's a
great question our opponent asks us the
same question just a second
okay so obviously by the transitive
principle we can play Queen D2 here and
CD Bishop takes a transposes into that
line but
in response to Queen to D2 my guess
is that block wants to move the Rook
let's leave that to the side for a
second
we have Alternatives here one thing we
can do is drop this Knight back and
remove the threat on the Knight and win
a Tempo against the rook and then we can
chase the bishop away with H3 but
we also have to calculate the move F3
after f3c takes D4 we can actually take
the bishop instead of taking the Rook
very easy detail to miss
how do we evaluate that position well
black probably will have to move the
rook in that position because the check
on H4 is almost never dangerous due to
G3
a little bit precarious there because we
can't Castle the F5 will be open and if
we play Rook F1 then our King will be
permanently stuck in the center so I
don't love that option
which means we're deciding between Queen
D2 and Knight to E2 Knight F3 is not an
option because black just takes twice
with a fork
Knight to E2 is what appeals to me the
most and I'll explain why there's
actually a positional component to this
decision
there is a bishop currently on D5 and
that's a pretty major Outpost but the
piece that we really want to occupy that
square the the best piece to occupy that
score would be a knight so E2 is a great
Transit point to eventually get to
Frankfurt airport eventually get to
either C3 or F4 and ultimately to D5
okay so now
I think most people would be inclined to
play H3
but that's not mandatory we can also
just leave the bishop on G4 and just
Castle
and the benefit of that is we could play
F3 afterward
chasing the bishop away but also
unpinning the Knight and creating a
little Pawn chain in the center
so
one thing I like
or one thing we have to look at after
castles is Knight F3 check
gf3 Bishop F3 but in that position I
think we can go Queen to D3 this is like
advanced calculation so I'll spell this
out after the game but long story short
I think we should just Castle a little
bit scary but nothing major and white is
definitely better
so the line I was just referencing is
what happens if black tries to sack the
Knight on F3
then recapture with the bishop and you
know this classic pattern with the queen
coming to the G file
yeah the the point of the defensive move
Queen Z3 is simple we need to unpin the
knight in that position because the
Knight can block a queen's check from G3
but
that will expose the queen so we
preemptively move the queen forward and
potentially create lateral defensive
options of Queen G3
should the bishop move okay
now we enter a different stage of the
game we're out of the opening we're into
the middle game let's see if we can
positionally outplay our opponent using
our biggest assets
and our biggest asset is the D5 Square
but we also have nice piece coordination
black Scott you know potentially weak
pawns and and underdeveloped kingside
that will grant us I think the two Tempe
that we need to develop Central pressure
Bishop B7 obviously
okay so I think F3 is
virtually automatic here again we'd have
to play check for Knight takes F3 but
that clearly doesn't work okay
now a big mistake would be to play
Bishop takes Bishop because that would
allow black to recapture with the pawn
and nullify our biggest strength black
would have the the D5 Square defended so
the obvious move here is Knight F4 I
think this is better than Knight C3
because Knight C3 walks right into B4
right so don't just choose a square at
random try to be discriminating when it
comes to understanding how to get a
piece to an outpost don't just blindly
put it on the first Square you see but
Knight F4 isn't even mandatory because
there's a logistical problem that
happens after Knight F4 let's say black
castles the issue is that we have
nowhere to put this bishop to make space
for the Knight to get to D5 because we
can't go back to B3 that walks into C4
and we lose our Bishop if we take on E6
black always recaptures with a pawn so
as much as I'd love to get an itd5 I
think that might have to go on the back
burner unless we don't see anything more
more effective to do so are there other
ways to approach this position well I
think there are
we've been looking at the positional
approach centered around getting our
pieces to a better score what if we try
to develop an initiative using our pawns
what about the move F4
so F4 is really scary for black because
this Knight doesn't have a lot of good
squares to go to
if the Knight drops back to G6 black
walks into a fork if after F4 black
plays Knight G4 we trap the Knight with
H3 so after F4 black might have to drop
back to D7
and that looks like a very awkward move
in that position I think we can even try
to hunt down some of Black's minor
pieces
I like the look of f4
oh I did miss Knight C4 that probably is
the best move that black can make but
then we have a check on C6 and we can
force Black's King to move over to f8
harming the the connection between the
Rooks which can be very very important
as the game moves to a more tactical
position
yeah F4 is uh an advanced move it's
Advanced but it's simultaneously obvious
like I think a newer player might play
up for
but
a more advanced player might fall in
love with the D5 Square which is kind of
a cool thing about Chess like sometimes
ignorance is bliss in chess and
ignorance makes you find the best move
just because you're not aware of the
enticing but wrong positional ideas
that somebody else would play
okay so let's see what our opponent
decides one detail if blackplay's Bishop
takes D5 we actually take the knight in
that position and win a piece because
the queen is under attack and the bishop
is under attack
Knight t7 okay what we expected okay now
I need a little bit of thinking time
because
we've got many options here even E5 has
to be considered just trying to blast
open the center and use the fact that
the king is currently stranded in the
center
but the cool idea that I came up with is
Bishop C6 anyway threatening F5
and trying to just trying to go after
Black's minor pieces
so let's consider it Bishop C6 Rook B6
which is a problem F5 Rook C6 Fe Queen
E6
Knight F4
Queen
take C4 unconvincing
although still looks very good for white
actually Knight T5 there
and if Queen C4
ah
so many
tempting options here let's consider E5
so E5 Pawn takes E5 Pawn takes E5
Queen doesn't have many squares it has
to take on E5
okay do we have a move there we don't
have Bishop F4 because if Queen takes D5
and the Knight defends The Rook in the
end so E5 takes takes takes
Bishop takes E6 Queen takes C6 Knight F4
Maybe
yeah that looks very Pro that actually
looks almost winning
just intuitively but maybe I miss
evaluating still I
am leaning
toward playing E5 and just trying to
smash through the barricades using
tactics
which kind of shows you
a different approaches that you can take
to a position we took this in a
completely different direction whereas
when I was playing the move Knight E2 I
was convinced that we would get the
Knight to D5 like a good Russian
Schoolboy but we've ended up playing a
completely different sequence of moves
if I'd have known that I wanted to treat
the position that way maybe the
immediate F4 would have been more
accurate but we'll sort the details out
after the game
so we go E5 D so here's the thing after
Pawn takes E5 Pawn takes E5 it's a
double attack on the queen
both the rook and the pawn are attacking
so that's why black can't take with a
knight
so after Pawn takes Pawn takes the queen
could also slide over to G6 but in that
position white is a very very powerful
move
that essentially wins the game it sends
black into a complete tailspin who sees
uh who sees the move after Queen G6 yeah
just Knight F4 with like a massive
attack you can stop calculating once you
see a move like that
so after Pawn takes E5 Pawn takes E5
Queen takes C5 a lot of people would get
excited by the alignment of the queen of
the organ say oh we just go Bishop F4
and we win the exchange but no because
you lose one Bishop on D5 and then you
lose the other bishop and the Knight
recaptures it on B8
so after Pawn takes Pawn takes Queen
takes we first take the bishop on E6
if black takes with a pawn then Bishop
F4 Works black has to take with a queen
well we already know that when the queen
is on E6 and G6 it allows the Knight to
jump into the game with Tempo Knight F4
looks very strong
and in that position I'm using my
intuition to evaluate it black is Uber
exposed in the center
and most importantly we could then play
the move rookie one to try to prevent
black from castling it's one of those
positions where if we can prevent black
from castling we're probably winning if
you give black one extra Tempo and they
Castle we might actually be like
borderline losing because we've
sacrificed a pawn and exposed our own
King
oh left an Uber yeah
hopefully that made
some like more subtle approaches like to
play Bishop C6 after G takes E5 but I
like the idea that we've come up with
just F take C5 open all the files and
stick our pieces on good Central squares
uh Rook Uber rather than a rook left LOL
okay d e let's just play FB quickly from
a Time consideration like we don't want
to spend too much time here because we
will need that time to meditate after
black makes his response so we go down
this path Knight F4 all of this is
pretty obvious I would recommend that
people spend you know 10-15 seconds per
move
but in this particular instance I want
to conserve a little bit of time for for
the middle game
because we're still only on move 20. so
now our opponent has another big Choice
he has to decide where to put the queen
and
my instinct would be to play Queen to D6
here
but the downside of that move is that it
again puts the queen and the Rook on
alignment so we could stick the Knight
on D5 and then we would be threatening
Bishop F4 with great effect
so where else can the queen go well
Queen C6 is possible but then the queen
loses contact with the bishop which
means that rookie one is super effective
because then it prevents black from
castling this should be winning for
white I think it is flat out winning
because all we've done is sacrificed
upon we haven't really made any other
huge commitments and what we have in
return for the pawn is just a massive
initiative
I would even call it an attack we're not
just calling the shots we're literally
going after the king
Queen to F6 wow that is not a move that
was even on my radar but maybe it's best
I don't know because it it walks right
into the discovery but I think what
you're noticing which I missed is that
lean F6 does threaten to exchange Queens
with Queen to D4 check and it's very
important I think
I mean I have a good example of this
when you're trying to conduct an
initiative of this kind don't
automatically rule out lines that
involve a queen trade because sometimes
even after the queen trade you might
just like win a minor piece or the
attack continues into the end game so
for example let's say black plays Queen
F6 and you're trying to consider the
move rookie one you see well that
doesn't work because black and force the
queen trade with Queen D4 check but you
have to keep calculating because there
even after the Queens are off we would
have had 95 winning the bishop on E7 our
opponent goes for the obvious move Queen
C6
now we have as I see it two candidate
moves or actually even three we can put
a queen on the E file we can put a rook
on the E file or we could start with the
more direct move Knight to D5
but Knight D5 looks like
it it
sort of commits a little bit too early
and maybe black can respond there with
with Knight to F6
and every trade makes the attack harder
to conduct so Knight F6 we can take the
bishop black takes with the King looks
terrifying but we're running out of
pieces
so I like the look of rookie one but it
occurs to me that black can play Knight
F6 in response and restrict our Knight
prevents it from reaching D5 which is
really annoying
rookie one Knight F6
and then black wants to play Rook B7 and
then he'll be ready to Castle so just
wait a second
this this should be promising but I have
to be very accurate
hi
this is harder than I anticipated
so rookie one Knight F6 do we have a
move there
I mean we can try to open up the queen
side but that doesn't seem to be
particularly promising
we need to there's Rook B7 there's this
annoying defensive move that defends the
bishop with the Rook
so maybe we should play Knight T5 after
all ah this is very very good defense by
our opponent
okay I'm starting to lean in the
direction of Knight T5 actually
okay
there's some super complicated lines I
was like whoa Bishop F6
in fact right away
okay that wasn't on my radar either that
is not a particularly natural move
okay
but I see its point I mean the point is
to give us this check on D4 I guess
yeah probably the best move something
tells me okay so
we can go Bishop F4
Bishop D4 King H1 Queen D5 Bishop B8
Knight B8 and then C3 picks up the
bishop
probably about equal there
hmm
Queen F3 also is interesting here Queen
F3 is very interesting
because Queen F3 sets up threats against
Black's Queen and prepares rookie one
I really really like the look of Queen
F3 but there he's got 95 but then Queen
E4
okay
huh
okay I'm gonna go with my gut here and
play Queen F3
which is which is another move that I
think
I wouldn't call it like it might be a
bad move but the basic idea is that it
prevents black from castling not because
you take the bishop then the queen
recapters but instead you have Knight to
E7
discovering discover check against the
queen
the other benefit of this move is that
it aims at the F7 punch so if black
delivers a check on D4 we simply shift
our King over and black has to deal with
an additional threat on F7
the battle revolves around one thing and
one thing only can we prevent black from
castling if yes if we can get the rest
of our pieces into the attack we should
have at the very very very least like
overwhelming practical compensation
because then the attack will have will
last for the rest of the game if we can
force black skin onto f8
um I'm also playing against Black's
Queen
which is a like Advanced thing to do
I'm trying to make it very uncomfortable
for Black's Queen because if Queen E6
then there's a fork if Queen D6 then the
bishop comes out with a pin
Rook C8 very logical move and I saw this
move and now we can't I think Force
Black's King to move with rookie one
check but is there anything better that
we could do I think rookie one is all
that we have because black is now
threatening to Castle
black Camp Castle now because the queen
is defended unless I'm missing something
I mean yeah you have Bishop takes H6
there but that's not
no we have to go rookie one and get f8
okay now I think we should bring our
reserves into the attack Bishop F4 makes
a lot of sense we don't really have time
for a move like C3 I'm afraid because
then the Knight jumps into E5
so at this point we just have to throw
caution to the wind and
get our pieces into the game
so
this would be my instinct which I'm
playing
basically without calculation because I
I think we have to try this move whether
it works or not without all of the
pieces we won't be able to break through
the the storm the barricades here the
attack is definitely not over
in fact it hasn't even begun yet we're
just bringing our pieces into the game I
would estimate that black probably can
defend here with some computer moves but
for a human this is wildly unpleasant
for black
and remember we've only sacrificed a
pawn this is something people often
forget like it's not like we have
sacrificed a minor piece or a rook we
don't need to hurry as much as we would
have to if we had sacrificed something
bigger yeah of course black can take B2
but that only helps us get our Rook to
where we want it to be anyway then we've
sacked two Pawns Bishop takes B2 we go
Rook a to D1 a lot of people I think
would instinctively play Rook B1
but that's just an empty one move thread
and the bishop wants to return anyway to
D4 with check so good example of like
not making the autopilot move if black
takes the pawn
another autopilot move would be like 97
but remember that that allows the queen
trade
and in the end of the line The Rook is
also hanging on A1
so so 97 is an idea in general but only
if for instance the king is on G8 or
something
rookie seven is not
a valid idea here unless the bishop
moves
okay
so now our opponent is starting to get
low on time
and there's a gorgeous idea if black
tries to run away with his King does
anybody see like a really really pretty
tactical move it might not even be
winning but it's a pretty concept
in response to in fact I think King G8
might be a decent move here
okay Bishop B2 nerves of Steel yeah
there was this move Rook to E8 check
deflecting The Rook so that 97 would
then pick up the queen
but it's a moot point we go Rook 81
immediately and Knight F6 okay now I
need to think in silence because this is
getting
Ultra Tactical
and we don't have much time three result
game
okay think think
mine isn't a bit of a haze right now
rookie 7 95
rookie 795 what do we have there
Uh crap 795 I don't like Bishop D6 Queen
takes D6 no
Knight takes F6 he plays Queen takes F6
oh
we can play C3
you can play Knight B6 we can play
Knight F6 Queen F6
Rogue D6
like I see so many convince attempting
options but nothing that like truly
appeals to me that's the big issue here
Knight F6 he also has Bishop F6
amazingly
incredible but there's no mate there
okay I'm gonna go C3 I'm gonna play the
slow move
I'm gonna play the slow move which I I'm
sure is not the best move it might even
be a very bad move but I'm playing also
for his clock here because
moves like C3 are are hard to face in
time pressure because it suddenly gives
black a very wide choice of options
and I'm well I'm I'm obviously trapping
the bishop I'm not attacking the bishop
yet but let's not neglect an idea like
Rook to E2 which would hit the bishop
and the bishop has a three but okay it's
a moot point takes takes
yeah but now I thought we have a tactic
but of course I miscalculated
but it might still be winning
Rook d8 check exists
and we might have to play it I don't see
another move we have to go Rook d8
but it's not over because black takes
one he obviously missed this move
but we might not even be better than I
mean
kind of gets Tactical
okay he has to take
I'm not gonna remove Queen C6 in case he
plays Queen E8 but
takes
we must have a win there
should C7 Rook Z1
Bishop C7 Rook D1
is dangerous for white suddenly
where's the win there must be a win here
it must be but we don't want to he can
go Queen E7 because of Rook D1 we go
Queen C7 he has her Cafe rookie eight
okay I think this move is probably our
best chance
hmm
I think Bishop C7 makes the most sense
Ricky and any blunders Bishop D6 yeah a
bit of an anticlimactic ending he played
way too quickly I think white is winning
there the only chance after Bishop C7
every other move loses instantly is Rook
to D1
I think our opponent completely failed
to look in that direction because there
black sets up the threat of Bishop G3
made I think our opponent assumed that
if he moves The Rook away from the
eighth rank we would have Queen A8 check
takes h8 but calculating one move
further there's Bishop G3 Checkmate so
my idea against Rook D1 would have just
been to play the com King F1
and try to get the king out of the the
range of the Rook so I think it's
winning for white but we'll check with
the engine wow what a what a crazy game
so first order yeah Rook do you want to
see equal
ing to the chess.com engine
it is equal but let's check with the
stronger chess face engine because these
lines are
hard even for the engine
okay we'll see
let's check the accuracy for still just
out of curiosity how bad it is
now copy this game to chess base
and I'm going to pull up the sort of the
strong stockfish
okay what the accuracy was it was good
it was 92 to 80 86 it was a high quality
game but I'm sure there are a lot of
mistakes nonetheless
okay let me pull up an instance of the
game
and let's jump into the analysis so
all right I am going to also pull up the
chat on my phone because I want to use
my other monitor for chess base
okay so just to make sure that we're on
the same page previously I had
recommended two openings against D4 E5
the first is at a lower level the Vienna
Gambit which is very very effective and
that's Knight F6 F4
and the second is uh before night Scotch
which we've been focusing on in the
speed run now before like 1800 we
wouldn't even get this position very
often and when we did people would go
either Bishop B4 or like Knight takes D4
make a bad move now of course most
people know that the main line is Bishop
B4 and we had this once I think that
game continued like Bishop D3 castles
castles and here our opponent played the
inaccurate move D6 after Bishop G5 we
scored a pretty quick Victory and you
can refer to that speeder on game four
and exploration of the main line which
is D5
uh but in this game I decided to spice
things up with the Belgrade Gambit so a
little history when was the Belgrade
first played it was first played
according to chess base
in
the year
what year
let me see in the year 1938
by Kurt Richter
who was a master not like a super famous
player it was played a good amount in
the 40s and 50s
Michael Tall played it three times in
the 19 no he played it five times so
tall was a big early proponent of the
bug ready to played it in his youth tall
played it at like age 16 and 17. so I
see two games from 1953
16 years old and two three games from
1954. let's all played it a bunch in his
early career
and then once people discovered like
Thelma Black's responses the Belgrade
fell out of fashion and hopefully once
again it'll acquire some degree of
popularity so the most popular move
in in
human games is Bishop E7 Bishop E7 is
considered by some to refute uh the
Belgrade Gambit completely but I was
able to find I think a couple of good
ideas that give white some life
so in particular against Bishop E7
there's this computer move Bishop to D3
you just develop your bishop and defend
the epon and this is a much more
dangerous idea than it looks because
okay typically black plays D6
yeah so here the move is is H3
that much I remember to prevents to
prevent Bishop G4 very important to
prevent Bishop G4 and if black castles
white also castles and in my opinion
this position is already quite
unpleasant for black so what makes this
position unpleasant for black well first
of all what happens if black takes the
Knight which is probably Black's most
practical option takes in the 95 but
still after Knight takes D4 this is my
game against Eric Hansen from the aim
chess rapid qualifiers and this position
is like a smidge better for white white
has a little bit more space I was
winning at the end of this game but
still if black plays carefully it should
be it should be equal like white plays
C4 and then white plays Bishop D2 and
rookie one black should be able to
equalize with another few careful moves
um but if black doesn't play Knight
takes D5 then things get a little bit
more dangerous so let's play Black let's
say black plays Bishop E6 white is
already slightly better after Knight
takes E7 and Bishop G5 because this pin
is very very hard to get rid of
okay the Instinct display H6 and G5 but
here after Knight takes G5 white is
already winning
this is a really cool line that I came
across when preparing the Belgrade
and why is this position winning how do
you judge that well the reason is that
the Knight on F6 is dreadfully weak and
the typical defensive mechanism is to
bring the king up to G7 now you're
watching on YouTube you should pause and
try to figure out how you actually
increase the attack on the Knight
because it's not the obvious move white
to plan win
what's the key idea
which wins on the spot by the way yeah
it's not Queen F3 which I think some
newer players might want to play because
this doesn't actually attack the Knight
Knight has enough Defenders you want to
explode the king side with F4 followed
by E5 to involve The Rook
so for example
black should probably move the queen
away
but now you still play E5 and black just
gets massacred on the king's side
d-e-f-e it's very easy to observe that
it's Checkmate like seven ways to Sunday
such as in this line where okay the
Queen's gonna come out to H5 and the
game is over
not even close
so this is one of the instances where
this line works like a charm if black
doesn't move they're Queen then E5 wins
the queen because in this position black
is nothing better than just like giving
up the queen for a rook in a piece but
obviously white is completely winning
here as well
so this is a cool line black and
circumvent this by playing H6 but that
is not a move that everybody's going to
be able to uncover and now
you get the bishop pair you go rookie
one and there's this Classic Plan where
you go B3 and Bishop B2 and try to
recover the d-pawn and if you can do
that you'll have a bishop pair and a
space Advantage I think this position is
easier to play for white even though it
is equal if black is careful
so the first sort of major Innovation
and again I don't know what the guy
recommends in the chessable course but
my move was always Bishop D3 here and it
worked really really well
a couple of other ones if black takes on
D5 immediately why is this dangerous for
black well already black has to decide
where to move this Knight
um vid it against me
played
no this is not what video played against
me but black is already worse here a lot
of people go Bishop before check
Bishop D2
and then they deliver another check with
the queen but here after Queen to E2 the
end game is better for white and there's
one important line to remember
let's say what black plays Bishop takes
D2 we take with the King obviously
because the queen trade is inevitable
Queen takes C2 check Bishop takes C2 and
now Knight to E7 now you might say well
we have to take on D4 and then black
takes on D5 and black keeps the extra
Pawn but here there's a couple of good
options but I really like the move D6
which is a classic idea you're losing
the pawn anyway so you're giving it up
in order to ruin your opponent's Pawn
structure permanently after Knight takes
D4 white has a very pleasant Advantage
this is like plus 0.5 You're Gonna Go
Bishop F3 You're Gonna Go rookie one
Black's Bishop is buried really really
really unpleasant position
so actually Knight takes D5 is a mistake
and a lot of GMS play this move black is
already worse according to the engine if
black plays Knight before
then obviously do not play Queen 64.
here you go Bishop C4 and secure the D5
Pawn and uh
the lines can get kind of crazy here
like if black gives you this check you
actually just want to slide the king
away to F1 and I was looking at lines
like these but this gets very very
Advanced and I'm not gonna bore you to
death uh with the like Ultra Advanced
details
the last move that I want to cover for
now is Knight C6 to B4 which is a a
common book recommendation and and is
considered to refute the Belgrade Gambit
by some
um this was first played in the year
1947 already
Yuri averback was one of the first
players to play it against Mikhail tall
and what's crazy is that tall actually
kind of knew the best line in the 1950s
obviously without accessing the engine
so in my opinion the best way
to give white practical chances here is
to play Knight takes F6 check
Queen takes F6
now you go A3 attacking uh the Knight
the Knight drops back to C6 and now
again you play this like neutral move
Bishop to D3 and this was a novelty when
I played it by again Samuel Sevin also
in the aim chess rapid qualifiers and
again I gotta I I got a very good
position here
just a moment okay so this is actually
what I confused with the game
continuation the point is that black
doesn't have an easy move if black plays
D6 who can tell me based on our
experience in the game what White's best
move is and you already know this if you
were paying attention to my in-game
commentary you should know what the best
move is yeah now you've repositioned to
B5 and in in theory or in practice this
is a very hard position for black to
play Black has to know a couple computer
moves most people who don't know this
position go Bishop D7 of course and
after castles white is already slightly
better I've had this line a bunch of
times here you bring the other Bishop
out and after Queen G6 Bishop takes E7
black is forced to expose his King and
bringing it to the center and here white
gets a very long lasting initiative with
Bishop takes C6 Bishop takes C6 now you
have a very powerful move Knight to H4
bringing the Knight over to F5 with
check obviously E4 is untouchable
and my line ends here you're going to
recover the d-pawn and you're slightly
better
okay
so that's another dangerous line for
black
as I was mentioning during the game if
black brings the bishop out in front of
the pawn chain that walks right into B4
so you can start by castling let's say
the black also castles E5 and Blacken
resign
here blackened literally resigned
because black gets massacred on the
king's side after Knight takes E5 you
trade and go rookie one
and the point is that the bishop on C5
is targeted not only with B4 but also
with Queen to H5 so here white literally
just wins a minor piece
black has to go to D5
but now in comes another incredible idea
C4
and if on Passat then Bishop H7 wins the
queen so again the queen has to move
let's say that the queen goes back to C6
and now the pawn storm begins B4 and
literally you just trap the bishop
Bishop D6 and C5 the bishop is trapped
as it is after Bishop B6 and C5 so this
C4 move really really easy to miss
finally if after rookie won the queen
goes back to D6 then you win just
because you have a massive King side
attack and black is not getting the rest
of his Queen side pieces out
so here black has to know to play D6 but
all these little details are like wins
and after D6 you played B4 and after
Bishop B6 you implement one last idea
that I'll show you which is to drop the
Knight back to D2 not an intuitive move
at all but the point is simple you want
to go F4 and build up a strong Pawn
Center then come back to F3 and slowly
but surely work on recovering the D4
Pawn they'll go Bishop B2 and you can go
like Grand Prix Style with Queen E1
Queen G3 in the engine actually likes
white here
so also not a refutation by any stretch
of the imagination
there are other moves and I think the
most underrated move for black is
probably Bishop C5
with the idea I think that if you want
to know like a quote-unquote reputation
is probably this because here Bishop G5
is the only logical move and now Bishop
comes back to E7 this is like a very
enginey line
and unfortunately I analyzed this I
looked at this position here white is
worse
and I came to the conclusion that white
has nothing better than to give away the
bishop go Bishop to B5 and basically go
for complete liquidation and likely a
draw like castles takes takes takes
takes takes black is not really better
here but it is a very hard position for
white to win so if black wants to make a
draw Bishop C5 is the way to do it but
that's a very rare move most people
don't come up with this move intuitively
because of Bishop G5
okay enough with the overview let's go
to the game H6 which is a move that I
wasn't too familiar with it's rare
and already my response was a mistake
yeah Bishop D3 is already a mistake
according to the engine of course I
confuse the line I confuse this with um
like night before
here the best move
is a relatively simple one you're
supposed to go Bishop C1 to F4
attacking the C7 Pawn okay so black
probably goes D6 and now we just recover
the pawn on D4 with a slight Edge much
less complicated than I made it out to
be
one other
important idea to be aware of this trap
also exists in the London system
I know Eric Rosen has won a ton of games
like this in the London system
only I could remember where this trick
is applied
trying to remember it's it's it's a
thing in the London maybe somebody can
even remind me but back to like the the
current position what is White's winning
move here what is White's winning move
here very very important to know now
it's not Queen E2 because black can
actually take and drop the Knight back
to E6 doesn't work
this move comes out of nowhere and it
wins on the spot
punch her opponent in the face not quite
all right somebody has to see it come on
guys I know it's late Knight B5 yeah and
the pawn on C7 cannot be defended God I
really want to remember what the London
system trick is because it's so similar
and a lot of strong players have fell
for it let me Google it London system
Knight B5 trick
five traps in the London system
I mean I'd have to go through all the
air crows and videos but I'll have to
leave that for another day
but after Knight B5 blackened resign
because C7 is lost
what does that mean that means that the
pawn any four is Untouchable and if
black tries to liquidate
black is gonna get into a a massively
cramped position where the bishop cannot
be developed because you take G7 and if
the bishop cannot be developed in black
is a very very hard time just moving
anything
uh so that's yet another unpleasant line
for black so the correct move here was
just Bishop to F4
um if in this position black does like
takes takes and Bishop B4 check this
essentially transposes into the line we
already looked at H6 doesn't really
change anything we don't need the G5
Square anyway so we looked at this
through the move order like takes takes
Bishop before Bishop D2
the addition of H6 does not really favor
Black in the slightest so good to know
H6 Bishop B4 is correct
okay so we played Bishop D3 which is
decent but definitely not uh the topical
move and D6 by our opponent was also a
mistake after D6 the position is about
equal due to Bishop B5 the correct move
was Bishop C5
and in fact H6 makes a lot of sense in
this context because now we can't go
Bishop G5 well how big of a deal is that
well it's a pretty big deal because if
we just Sleepwalk our way through the
rest of the opening black is going to
get sort of an ideal setup where G5 is
covered D4 is defended and we can't
engineer our like classic counter play
with B4 so it's like minus over plus
here we're in trouble because why does
no white is out of ideas
like the engine move is A3 trying to
prepare B4 but black can obviously go A5
and prevents it and white just has to
like play down upon right and go like
Bishop D2
black castles and the engine finds some
way to generate counter play with B4 but
this is very very iffy so a good example
of like trying to use common sense
rather than remembering the lines which
is something I always preach in and then
don't practice like you're facing an
unfamiliar move don't try to remember
your analysis try to use common sense
and Bishop D3 just doesn't pass the
smelt this so D6 allows Bishop B5 and
now things get really interesting so A6
Bishop A4
B5 Bishop B3 makes a lot of sense
now I think our opponent made another
inaccuracy 95 leads to very interesting
complications according to the computer
the correct move would have just been a
simple developing move Bishop E7
and the position almost resembles a rue
Lopez in fact probably this could have
even transposed from Marie Lopez
White Castles black castles
and A4 is now the best move typical real
Lopez idea and the position is about
equal very very double edged white has
enough compensation for the pawn but
probably not more than that
like Bishop G4 leads to
crazy complications white recovers the
pawn on C7
okay and things continue a position is
about equal
Queen B7 Knight T5
Knight E5 just a very very complicated
middle game with chances for both sides
but our opponent tried to force things
off the Border Knight E5 now we had to
see Knight takes D4 this is a critical
idea of course the original Noah's Arc
trap which I mentioned happens in the
real Lopez
and the original Noah's Ark shop
involves White playing D4 overzealously
black plays B5 then blackplay's Knight
takes D4 and in this position white has
to Gambit away the pawn because if you
take on D4 black wins a minor piece with
C5
white plays Queens E5 black plays Bishop
B6 you might think that you have a
repetition of moves
but the bishop has gone from C8 to D7
which means The Rook is now defended
which means the black can now play C4
tons of games in the database I have to
refresh to get the uh game open again
so that's the sort of skeleton skeletal
idea of pushing the pawn forward two
squares and I would generalize this to a
type of idea that is missed very very
frequently in a lot of openings where
the the basic point is that you push the
pawn forward attacking one piece that
piece has to move and then you push the
pawn forward one more Square attacking a
piece that then is is trapped and this
can be a very hard pattern to spot two
famous examples that I've shown before
on stream and the alkyne this trick
exists and Gary gazparov lost a very
famous game in which he could have won a
minor piece
with that trick so here we go
if I can get chest space to work okay so
here is Gary's game
against Alex you're malinski
from a under 18 Soviet Championship
final round this was a super important
game
and crazy things happen in this position
where Alex Goes
Alex Goes Knight a to E7
and Gary like quickly plays Knight B3
and continues playing he ended up losing
the game what did he miss well obviously
I'm talking about it so now you should
see this very quickly the winning idea
is to go G4 you attack one minor piece
Force the bishop back in G5 traps the
bishop on F6 that's why 97 was wrong
because it cuts off The Bishop's Escape
Route
okay the second example
uh that that is in a similar kind of
category is tibiakov against kamski and
this feature is like a really really
beautiful move that sets this idea up
so this is a young gotta who fell victim
to this idea
let's see who remembers this example
because I've definitely shown it before
in the speed run
kamski tibiakov sagada was not a GM yet
neither was tiviakov and in this
accelerated dragon
plays a pretty natural move he
centralizes his Knight and offers some
traits
so black to play and win the game by
force let's see who can spot or who can
remember
the the beautiful winning idea and this
starts with a very paradoxical move that
is another one of those mental blocks
that prevent you from looking at certain
types of moves what could that first
move be it's not no Queen B6 blender is
the queen
and what seems to be the least natural
way to trade pieces here for black
so what are we taught in the Sicilian
and the dragon not to do yeah we're
taught not to give away the dark scored
Bishop
but if you look at this carefully you
start seeing that there's a cluster fill
in the blank in the center
so you might say oh let's go E5 but here
the bishop is not frapped it has E3 but
what if we could take away the E3 Square
by doing what by playing E6 first
Knight F4 E5 is a fork so the Knight has
to go back to E3 and now E5 traps the
bishop it has a seven but after Rook B7
it's out of squares and gamski was
forced to give the bishop up and he ends
up losing the game so this is like a lot
of ideas rolled up in one
but another thing to file away into your
mental directory of tactical ideas where
you push the pawn attack one minor piece
and then Advance It Forward trapping
another
the most famous instance of this is the
Noah's Ark which is why I had to look
for a concrete way to get this bishop
out and we found one which is takes and
Bishop D5
and I think the evaluation of this
position hinges largely on whether black
can play CD and according to the engine
this position is equal
oh this is gonna get really juicy so F3
allows Knight takes F3 and apparently
it's still equal but black obviously has
a huge initiative
so this is out of the question
but what does black do after Queen cd2
oh here we go again black has an
incredible move it's the only move that
doesn't lose let's see who can find it
it's not
totally like out of the ordinary
because you should notice that the queen
and the Malcolm Tucker on a roll it's
Bishop F3 they came queen and the King
are on forkable squares so you might say
ah well let's play Bishop to H3 but here
white can advance the F Pawn and connect
the queen of the G Pawn so it's
important to put it on F3 to also
immobilize the F Pawn and things get
wild here so why you can actually Castle
in Black's face but then why it gets
checkmated this is like a lobster
pincermate this is Unstoppable so white
has to defend the G2 Pawn the only way
to do that is to play Rook G1 but now
more tactics Bishop takes G2 you can't
take because of the four
so white can try a really devilish move
Bishop C6 check in order to deflect the
knight from E5 and if the Knight takes
them The Rook takes and light is up in
exchange but black doesn't have to take
the bishop but king d8 would be a
horrible blunder it would allow a sudden
mating attack so black has to find King
E7 here yes Jen white still plays Queen
A5 setting up threats of Queen C7
and you just get wild tactical
complications just look at the engine
line and you will freaking fall off your
chair Queen F3 all of these are only
moves Bishop D5 G5
A4
D3
and of course the sun's in a draw CD
Knight D3 King D2
now for some reason black doesn't take
on F2 with check that loses oh of course
this position white is this winning the
queen naturally very obvious Alliance to
Black has to go back to E5 and you get a
repetition of moves King goes back to E1
and this is the way that the game would
have ended totally natural simple line
alternatively alternatively
white can play the immediate Queen A5
why does it have to play Bishop C6 check
and here we get a simpler repetition
Knight F3 check
King can't go to E2 because of the Rook
hanging with Chuck
and now black has to go back to E5 and
white is nothing better than to repeat
moves
here if black takes the Rook he gets
mated with Bishop C6 and queen C7
so amazing black had to find CD Bishop
G4 and Bishop F3 and this is findable
I would say that it is findable if you
see Bishop F3 this is the key move that
I think our opponent missed if he had
seen it I think he would have realized
that well black gets massive practical
play for the exchange and I can sense
that there was something I just couldn't
put my finger on it I think most people
would play this move but this is just an
empty one move threat that allows white
to play Queen F4
so yeah so that's that's that
and instead our opponent played the
immediate Bishop G4 allowing us to
conserve our Knight with Knight to E2
and now clearly white is better Rook B8
and we Castle black plays Bishop B7 and
this is okay not this but the next
position is another critical moment
we go F3 our opponent goes Bishop E6 and
now we have to decide whether to proceed
positionally or tactically which is
always a very hard decision
I'm pretty confident that F4 is at the
very least a practically promising move
to reiterate what I was saying during
the game the problem with Knight F4 is
that you reach kind of an impasse
because the moment you take the bishop
you correct black spawn structure and
you can't drop back to B3 because you
get your Bishop trap so I didn't see a
future for this Knight once it reached
F4
if you had wanted to play this more
positionally
the computer recommends kind of an
interesting idea which is in fact to
take on E6 and then play F4 so this is
almost a cross between playing it
positionally no it is positional it is
very positional so now rather than
playing E5 which is what we kind of did
in the game white can try to carve out
the D5 Square yet again with what move
this is a very positional idea
yeah white plays F5 classic concept
obviously if black plays E5 then you're
completely winning strategically you get
the Knight to D5 and if black just does
not react if black castles think United
for the right you go Knight F4
and again you forcibly are getting your
knight to D5 if black takes you have
Queen D5 winning the Knight on C6
so already after Knight F4 black is in a
bit of trouble
so this would have been this is super
super Advanced you like correct black
spawn structure and then Undo It by
pushing your Pawn forward super
interesting
I considered the move A4 but black just
goes B4 I wasn't really sure what we
gained from that so yeah A4 is a move to
be aware of in all of these positions
but in this case I don't really see what
it gives way okay so instead we went
super super tactical we went F4 and E5
black has to take
and black has to take again
now Bishop takes C6
again according to the strong stockfish
there was a stronger move and the
stronger move was to start with Knight
F4 this is almost unfindable like Bishop
takes C6 is so natural to get the queen
onto a square where you can attack him
at Tempo but apparently this was even
stronger but we're gonna ignore that
moment for now Bishop E6 Queen E6 is
totally natural Knight F4 and our
opponent was Finding only moves Queen C6
only move to keep the balance
now Knight T5 is also best
so my quick explanation of why the other
moves fail Queen d695 just looks
terrible for black because Bishop F4 is
coming
and if black tries to trade the pieces
with Knight F6 we still go Bishop F4 and
we just win the exchange and get a
technically winning end game
the other squares are even less
appetizing Queen b695 and if the queen
moves to the f file you're walking into
a discovery so by process of elimination
this is the only logical move now a
moment where I think 95 of players would
go rookie one this is such a natural
move but it's minus over plus white is
almost losing after rookie one and it's
because black plays Knight F6
and the point of this move is twofold
the first is that you restrict the
Knight on F4 completely but the second
the more important one is that if white
plays for instance Queen E2 oh you can
even Castle immediately incredible
tactics Queen takes C7
and Rook ae8 wins The Rook on E1 because
white is not coordinated but you could
also go Rook B7 and then Castle
and we already know that once black
castles there is no longer any
compensation
so therefore we had to take more
immediate measures to prevent gasoline
that's where 95 comes from okay Bishop
F6 is a really impressive move
um I was expecting of course Knight F6
and here
I was gonna take the bishop black takes
back and we play Bishop F4 and
oftentimes the evaluation in such
positions are equal what do I mean when
I say in such positions so it's
positions where the king is going to be
weak for the foreseeable future
so often white has enough compensation
but not more than that like black spawn
balances out the lack of King's safety
but black also has to be very very
careful like Rook beat a d8 loses on the
spot to the move rookie one check and
the King can't move back because if
Queen takes Rook mate so there's a lot
of mine mines that black has to avoid
stepping on so correct is rugby C8
and okay like the game continues we play
Bishop E5 I would take white here any
day but it's all zeros according to the
engine after Rook hd8 okay so hopefully
that made sense
yeah a lot of very technical lines here
but still this is how you learn
how to play Dynamic positions instead
our opponent put the bishop on F6
and of course we bring our Queen into
the game with Queen F3 oh and this loses
this is a losing move
wow black had a winning line here
winning like plus two and I am using the
computer a lot here but that's only
because like I have to otherwise we
won't get to the truth of this position
the correct move here was Bishop F4
which I rejected because why did I
reject Bishop F4 I don't even know
black has to move the Rook to C8 and we
play Queen E1 and Rook to D1
uh with long-term attacking chances
white is white is doing great here what
did I miss after Queen F3
so the correct move was Bishop D Fortune
which of course I saw but in this
position I thought that black is losing
because he can't Castle due to 97 and I
missed a pretty simple move
missed a pretty simple move what is the
move that I missed Knight D7 to E5 which
hits the queen and also protects Black's
queen against various discoveries they
might say well why is this such a big
deal white can just yeah with Queen E4
but now the White Knight is victimized
lockley's Rook d8 and white is busted
like the Knight hangs there's no more
ideas you have to go back to C3 allowing
black to Castle was just a technically
winning position
so after 95
white has to take Extraordinary Measures
and instead the more resilient move is
Queen G3 with the idea of meeting Queen
takes D5 not with Queen takes G7 this is
an empty move black just defends easily
but rather with C3
and this Still Remains very very tricky
because
after black castles
white play C takes D4 black lacy takes
D4 you can play Bishop takes H6 here and
here black has an only move without this
move black is losing here
what does black do to defend G7 without
giving up an exchange important concept
to be aware of Knight E5 back to G6 very
good white is out of attacking ideas and
black consolidates his extra Pawn
so completely missed 95. and this just
shows you why leading with the queen is
often a bad idea because the queen is
both a super powerful attacker but also
a massive liability and it's a
double-edged sword kind of thing
so Queen F3 was a mistake but in
response Rook C8 was also a mistake and
now the position remains equal
King f8 Bishop F4 so now we bring our
Bishop into the attack Bishop takes B2
is best according to the engine
Rook 81 and our opponent defended
perfectly here Knight F6 is again best
and C3 is the best move so this time I
did
you know I did come through
and just a quick window into what I was
trying to figure out here my inclination
was to take on F6
but the problem here is that black just
takes back with the bishop
of course the point is Queen takes F3
gets checkmated this is a beautiful
mating pattern
and if black plays Queen takes F6 well
then you have like a move like Rook D6
right with an attack but black takes
back with a bishop and you don't have
this deflection because the bishop
controls d8 and white just has no ideas
here you have a check on D6 this looks
very tempting but it's a dead end
because the king travels to H7 and white
is out of ideas again
so all of these forcing moves just don't
lead anywhere and that's where I came up
with the idea of essentially keeping the
tension
now what can white do to keep the
tension well the an easy way to improve
our chances is to cut off the bishop to
play C3
um and amazingly our opponent finds the
only moves to draw Bishop takes C3 is
correct
and this is a great instance of our
opponent blundering and getting in his
own head because he chatted me that he
blundered Rook d8 and just kind of gave
up hope assumed assumed that the
position was lost but in fact it's equal
amazing so Bishop takes E3 is the only
move
If instead black tries to run with King
G8
here
the best move is Bishop E5 and white
keeps A Massive Attack
notice that you don't corruptate because
of King H7 and black survives
so Bishop C3 is correct
check takes takes takes
now Bishop C7 is also correct and this
forces black into finding an only move
and that only to move the saving
resource was Rook to D1
and again the point is that in this
position white cannot capture The Rook
on h8 because of checkmate
now my plan against Rook T1 was to
evacuate with the King to play King F1
this actually loses to Bishop H4 check
the correct move here
after Rook D1 would have been to force a
draw white has nothing better than to
force Perpetual which you can do in a
variety of ways but an easy way to force
Perpetual is like this
the reason that King F1
is bad is because black plays Bishop H4
then puts the Rook anyone then runs the
king over to G8 and remember that black
is up material here black has two Rooks
and two pawns for the queen
but who can tell me what the saving idea
is after G3
this seems to cut off and attack both
the rook and the and the bishop at the
same time
and all of this hinges on one critical
move
rookie six but I can give you a check
but the king runs up and discovers an
attack on the queen so you still can't
take the bishop and finally black
consolidates
so King F1 is just too slow
it's a draw also possible is to give a
check and come back to F3
remember earlier piece of advice when
you're trying to disarm a discovery
attack the tail of the discovery don't
try to attack the bishop try to attack
the piece that's actually giving the
check that way you can avoid
you know the brunt of the discovery
and here actually black needs to be very
accurate or no Rook A1 Queen E4 check
now black plays King D7 you play Queen
D5 check and black can take on C7 and
then white picks up the rook in the
corner it's still a draw but black can
even hide behind the bishop with a crazy
crazy
uh Perpetual check check
here
check here so black doesn't touch the
bishop because the moment black touches
the bishop you win The Rook in the
corner this is still a draw but here
black has to work for it
just an insane insane complications
um but all of this was correct and in
circulate of course that loses the game
it loses all of the pieces you just lose
the rook and also the bishop so I had a
game like this even in this very speed
around where I blundered my queen and
then it like turned out to be the
correct move so you should never give up
hope like this right even after a
blunder you should just
consider the situation as it is and try
to find the best resource rookie 8 was
an emotional reaction by our opponent
and obviously didn't didn't blundercheck
didn't didn't see Bishop D6
wow what an absolutely Wild game and an
introduction to the Belgrade Gambit so
what are the important points of this
game and you're lost I'm lost that kind
of was the point of my explanation and
I'll bring this all together nicely in
the end but a couple of key points after
Knight T5 we explored some of Black's
options oh last thing I wanted to point
out if black takes on e4 which of course
is super common at the lower levels
again you play in like the modern
Belgrade style where you just develop
your pieces you go Bishop D3 you castle
and you can explore this on your own but
basically white gets massive
compensation for the two pawns this is
virtually unplayable for black so we
looked at 95 we looked at night before
we looked at Bishop E7
and of course our opponent played a rare
move to which I should have responded
Bishop F4 instead I won Bishop D3
allowing Bishop C5
but now the position almost transposes
into our Rue Lopez
we talked about the Noah's Ark trap and
ways to avoid it uh which I did by
attacking the rook in the corner only
move then black had this crazy CD Bishop
G4 resource sacking The Exchange which
he missed giving me a clear advantage
now the engine finds this bishop E6 F4
F5 idea to carve out the D5 Square would
have been the easiest way to solidify an
advantage and now the craziness begins
once the Center opens up
Knight F4 Queens D6 by and large it was
pretty accurately played by both of us
with the major exception of Queen F3
this was a big blunder allowing Bishop
d495
and of course the second major boner was
all the way in the end all of this was
correct and really it's sad but rookie 8
was was the losing move Rook D1 would
have kept in equal position
probably your reaction to all this as
well those lines were interesting like I
was entertained hopefully but what it
you know what do I learn from this like
what what is the key takeaway from the
speedrun and honestly the biggest
takeaways that there is none and what
you should take solace in is the fact
that as you can see I'm probably I'm
just as confused as you are in these
wild positions so when you get to a
certain level when the position is this
chaotic it's not like title players have
a certain way of approaching it that
prevents you from making blunders and so
if you're trying to beat higher rateds
that's why the common device is always
to go into sharp positions because in
sharp positions there's just a much
higher probability that a detail will be
missed
um but
at some point you just have to rely on
your intuition and my intuition was
largely correct that white is okay here
but as you can see I missed like a
gazillion of these details and uh there
is nothing to understand in these types
of positions you have to understand
certain guidelines such as the fact that
okay you sacrificed upon you should not
be afraid to go for what I call a
long-term attack like here for instance
you should not be afraid to just trade
and play Bishop F4 you shouldn't
catastrophize when you've only
sacrificed a pawn and sometimes you just
need to go for long-term pressure
against the king when nothing immediate
manifests itself
but the other thing is that these wide
open positions have no guiding
principles you just need to calculate
you need to pick up on tactical patterns
such as like the undefended queen or
Forks or pins like you have to do all of
that grunt work but by and large you're
on your own it's the Wild West in these
positions and that's why calculation is
ultimately the most important skill in
chess because it allows you to play
these positions without making a blunder
on every move and that's that
crazy game we've had a couple of them
good game to my opponent thanks again
any final questions this was a bit all
over the place for for a speedrun
presentation but I don't think there's
any other way of like analyzing this
game other than just being all over the
place and looking at a bunch of cool
lines and you know ending at that
yeah super super cool cool stuff
all right thanks everybody all ended
here I want to remind everybody on
YouTube that if you want to support me
you like my content subscribing really
really helps
you know it's I'm fighting the algorithm
so every person who tells their friends
about the channel obviously if if you
enjoy the content is a massive help to
me my ultimate goal is to reach 500k
Subs in six months
super ambitious but I think we can do it
thanks everybody
and I'll see you guys later thanks for
hanging out goodbye
foreign
[Music]